[Music]
hey guys how are you
today before we get into the vlog i just
want to give a really quick shout out
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
today's video make sure to stick around
at the end of the vlog because we'll be
talking more about them
well that was cute that was your attempt
at spanish adorable
uh they don't know all them play home
now although now
like oh my god oh my god stay home
they
that's what that means anyway hello
people
you guys might have noticed this thing
right here in the background
this thing so last night i got pretty
bored i was just sitting here at my desk
because see i'm on my desk right now
which by the way look look look it's
amazing
we'll get there we'll get there hold on
we transformed many things in this room
yeah i am a fan now right so last night
i was really
really really bored so then i was like
man i'm staring at this like
empty white wall here and i'm not a fan
of white walls at all like
i don't know if you could tell but i'm
like trying to fill up every single
space in this whole house with like
patterns and color and vibrancy and i'm
just like i don't like
white walls so here the closet doors
that's what it's called
closet doors i decided to outline
this with electrical tape because i was
just staring at this i'm like what can i
do to spruce this up
and then the middle part of the square
was just so
bare still with just the outline that i
was like maybe i can
i can cover it with whatever wallpaper
we have which we have a lot of this
wallpaper
and then i did these four squares and
then i realized i'm like you know what
this doesn't really go with this you
know what i mean like all of this
like all this is like one kind of style
but this
just doesn't really match it so then i
was like
well i did all this work should i keep
it i don't know
i'm like whatever's about it it at least
like made the closet doors
somewhat fun i guess but then i realized
like wait
next door of this room which is isaac's
room behind this wall
i have this huge art
work thingy and it used to be from ikea
and i ended up doing this to it it's
just like
one gigantic piece of
pattern and this this used to be
the ikea frames that we had and then i i
ended up covering it with
wallpaper and hung it up here so this is
in his room because that was just a huge
blank wall now we got to figure out what
to do here but then i thought maybe i
could just move that closet door and
leave it here
and it would match since he already has
the pattern in his room
and i asked isaac i'm like oh what do
you think do you like it
if you don't like it it's okay you can
just take it down because nothing's like
permanently
attached to that and he's like no i like
it i really like it so
what we're gonna do is remove this door
switch it out with his door and then
bring
it back but then that means i'm back to
square one what do i do with this
blank closet door i did consider the
fact that
i could just use a different wallpaper
so i have this with leftover wallpaper
from our bathroom so
maybe i can use that and then instead of
electric like black electrical tape i
can
look into like a gold tape and then
maybe
outline the squares with gold so i'm
kind of leaning towards that what do you
guys think let me know can you imagine
it picture it
that this wallpaper with gold squares so
i ended up doing this too i don't know
if i ever talked
about this with you guys but same thing
this was
another ikea artwork that i had from her
previous homes
and i decided to wrap it up with the
same wallpaper
that we used for the big mood set
because we had a ton left over and the
girls didn't want it and i was like
i'll take it so i ended up using the
wallpaper for this
and i also spray painted this gold
because this was
silver just like isaac's look at what i
got to do i still have to like
mod podge this or something like somehow
fully secure it so there's not that
weird
like dense that's pretty much that
and then that's pretty much that what we
got over here
wait it's a beauty right right right
here
is your hair oh yeah it is a work in
progress yes
yeah so what happened so i just got my
hair re-permed
today and so the first time i did it it
was like a baby step into
perming and what it was like and i only
got like wavy hair out of it
and because i was i was scared of doing
curls so this time around i went
a little curlier they kind of because i
thought it was
too similar to just straight hair before
so now i'm like trying to get it more
textured and obviously permed
yeah the last time i was like is it
perimeter is it not you know kind of
right
it's one of those anyways now i'm also
just reading up on how to
properly take care of it because i feel
like i might have messed it
messed up my perm the last time around
because i didn't
know how to take care of it properly and
what happened to this time around
oh this time i came back and you know
when it dries out and like before i left
they
they did like blow dry my hair which is
you know things you're not supposed to
do on your own which is blow dry your
hair
uh during the first two days of the perm
but
also uh no don't shampoo your hair and
what i'm reading right now is to not
even wet your hair at all like just
leave it the way it is don't touch it
don't do nothing what did the salon tell
you
my salon said no no shampoo they said
you could wet it
i could wet well i'm also reading some
some sites are saying that you can wet
it too
so great it seems like it's one of those
like toss-up
questions like i don't know it depends
on which school i thought i'm trying to
get to
to the point that you ended up wetting
it by the time you got back home yeah i
really wanted to show you how curly it
is because when it's wet it's really
when it
curls up into itself and it looks really
badass so i really wanted to show tiff
what it looked like and so i went i went
with my hair and
now i'm like regretting doing that
because now it's dry and it's like it's
just like straight it kind of lost its
curls again
but i did see a photo oh the picture
that you sent me in the car
it did show really well like the curls
and then comparing it from the first
perm photo to the second perm photo like
wavy
yeah like the first one was more wavy
but this one like it
it came out a lot better but yeah i
think maybe from
wetting it and also like you tend to run
your hands through your hair a lot so
maybe that made it
lose its girl curly effect somewhat true
i don't know we'll see what happens but
how does it look right now
it looks it looks wavy oh yeah it's wavy
yeah
but like for example this one right here
you kind of lost the curl but
maybe it just works better with product
in it like you know like i gotta get a
wet so it's curly and then i put product
in and it kind of holds it in that curly
position
yeah otherwise it probably looks like
this but it still looks good
i still like it i like it it has texture
yeah it's interesting
yeah okay well back to this though
because i said i'll talk about this
i did my desk i finally did the contact
paper if you follow me on instagram you
already saw it in my stories
but yeah i ended up just wrapping this
entire thing
with the contact paper so now i can say
100 my desk is complete
oh and then also i didn't show you guys
but yeah i ended up lining all the
drawers
with this chevron black and white
chevron pattern
so now i don't have to worry about this
being all ugly
because see that's ugly now it's pretty
and then also i ended up doing this one
with the contact paper because i had
some leftover paper
and i thought it would just be really
cute to also have this be all marble
because this is a pretty cool ottoman
you can turn it around and sit on it or
you could turn it around
and put stuff on it and then also check
this out
it's the kindle that casey got me for my
birthday
yeah i've been downloading it i've been
downloading a whole bunch of books oh
yeah
and reading and like playing with the
settings and figuring out what's
really fun and what would be really
great
what was that cutest moment of your
experience with that kindle was our on
our way back
from your birthday dinner and you're
opening it and you were like you know
you just finished like doubting
the last glass of wine you're like
oh my gosh it's so cute just look at it
isaac just
look at it it just looks crazy oh my
gosh it's just so
cute look at my phone put my phone on
top look it's just so
tiny it's so cute look at this
see isn't it so adorable it's like the
tiniest little thing ever it's like a
small
little ipad and i get to read i get to
read on it though
you're cute and intelligent at the same
time
thanks baby i don't know if you guys are
catching a glimpse right over here
but i didn't i don't think i talked
about this yet with you guys
but ta-da look a fan
drew this portrait of us about a year
ago they sent it to us
and they actually drew one of
practically everyone in the jk crew
and then i finally framed it and i just
hung it up here in the hallway
i would love to shout out who this is
focus focus focus
why isn't it focusing that name i think
it says
rk ryan or i honestly can't make that
out
but whoever you are thank you so so so
much and then hit me up on instagram so
then i can shout you out
and thank you for this portrait and now
we have
in our hallway so i really appreciate
that
it's been pretty nice having it up here
and then also
i did hit up bo guy who did this this
portrait
and then i asked him if he's down to do
a portrait of the fam
and he was like yeah so we're working
together on that
and i can't wait to bring that into the
office because then maybe you could go
like somewhere over here
we have more portraits and then this
time because i was telling him i'm like
oh
something casey i'm like we don't have
any portraits of the three of us
with our cats either so i'm like we have
to get that we have to like
cement that forever in some sort of art
form
right and i really like this artist like
i really really like his style
and like his color palette yeah and like
i'm excited to see
his rendition of moi yeah
for our family too oh and speaking of
art oh yeah
you're so funny this is a
the office portrait thingy what do you
call this
so from this guy i already forgot his
name but he was the one that created
danny phantom
me stupid nikki we met him when we were
at the l.a comic-con
was it last year something like that but
yeah we ended up buying
this this one's really cute so we hung
that one up and then we hung
this up case shall we go downstairs
yes it is an early christmas it is an
early christmas for us
let's go all right so santa came
early earlier today actually yep and
uh it was it was interesting he was
wearing a
a kobe mask and he was wearing a ups
outfit but
regardless i know santa was just trying
to
be safe yeah be incognito about the
whole process
running our christmas presents for the
season and it is a new
75-inch tv
that's still gigantic think about our
time when we were growing up
like 55 was like massive true but it's
like this is like a
dad buy you know like gigantic it's true
i mean
my dad's tv is like 75 inches but then
when you're growing up or like you're
finally on your own and as a young adult
it's like you know
like that's that's a big tv for like an
early 20s something you know
five inches so i feel really like grown
as
this guy now so today is
december 1st on black friday i was like
cool what if we try to get a new tv a
bigger tv because this
tv does look really small with this wall
like it's just there's a lot of white
wall happening
and so i looked up some deals and we
found a nice
deal for this one and so now we're gonna
attempt to install it on the wall
and i'm saying attempt because you
feeling strong today
i know i'm like i'm gonna need isaac's
help because
this kid is like getting stronger than
me now these days so
he's stronger than me mm-hmm yeah he's
going through a crazy growth spurt but
first i wanted to point out
how we decorated for christmas
so this is like our very very sad
decorations
i think it's nice it's really sad it's
kind of sad
no but yeah so usually i have the the
tree right here but
i found my old ipod and this is the only
cable that we have to charge it but the
other end
it only connects to the the piano show
them that show
the sound that you're like hey hey casey
you remember this sound oh yeah
look do you guys remember that yeah that
old like clicking
sound from the ipod it's so nostalgic
i love it but anyway back to christmas
decorations
so the christmas tree usually goes here
and then this little train thingy goes
right here but like i said we moved it
in the meantime so we could charge that
ipod
and then look outside we ended up
like just wrapping lights and ornaments
and putting ornaments
all around these cute little trees well
they're not little
christmas times nine we have nine
christmas trees
we do that's how festive we are i think
we outgrew it ourselves
yeah but i guess when you look in here
it's like
that's okay it's okay yeah we just had
like
this really sad garland and then this
really pathetic little santa
and then these really really small
very aromatic but small sad
pine cones these really really small sad
candles sorry what'd you say about that
number third oh and then this really
small
set christmas blanket it's really sad
it's really small
i don't know yeah i like it's our first
year having
this space and we didn't have a whole
lot to work with
in our previous homes because there were
apartments and
actually we hooked up the last place for
christmas that living room
that's true what happened with all that
stuff oh i got rid of a lot of it
because i
actually didn't like a lot of those
decorations oh i thought we like lost
all because you know how we had that
garland so like
so there's a mysterious uh there's a
mystery happening before us
we used to have this garland right this
one this is what we're talking about
this yeah that's a new one though yeah a
new one i want to replace it but
apparently
we had one it was in a box and who knows
what happened to that box
but now i'm thinking were there other
stuff in that box that
it was lost in that were also missing
and that's why the last place was able
to be all decked out and christmas stuff
all the time
yeah so when we were moving i was
very mindful of trying to only keep the
things that
make us happy and it's just like really
like
brings us joy and there were a lot of
christmas decorations like for example
we had this
one santa like it looked like a doll
like a santa doll and isaac
hated that santa so i made sure to get
rid of that and then we had this other
like
like clear snowman thing and just
pointless because it didn't even add any
decorative element because of the fact
that it was clear
and it was one of those like globe kind
of things where like you put it upside
down and then like there's a whole bunch
of glitter but then
just to have it standing somewhere it's
just pointless so anyway i got
rid of a lot of stuff that i'm like this
does not give us
joy and i'm thinking i might have
accidentally
thrown the or old garland in one of
those boxes that i was trying to keep
but i accidentally got rid of it so
anyway we bought another garland it's
okay this one's a lot more volatile it
has the lights in it
the last one didn't have lights did have
lights baby it was identical
thank you though this is what it looks
like
ignore the thawing chicken yeah casey's
going to be grilling for dinner
and then here are the little lights i
think our backyard's finally complete
now with uh oh cause you painted the
poles oh yeah
i didn't tell you guys this was silver
like really crummy gross
ugly and i painted it brown so it's
that one this one and the one in that
corner so
now it looks a lot better because before
it looked like it was under construction
still yeah we had construction pieces
just sticking out of our ground
yeah and then we also added these rocks
so we decided to not cover this after
all just
here you go there's the rocks yeah we
didn't want to mess up our ac unit
everyone's saying like yeah keep it
distance from the blind and the vents
and then
ac lifespan and all that stuff so
anyways and then we finally got the
string lights up too
yeah that's true we haven't shown you
guys that yet
man wait till you guys see it at night
it looks so good
i need to paint this beast of a project
so gotta do that and then also
eventually though we do want to buy a
whole bunch of plants
and just put a whole bunch of pots here
because we did buy
two plants the christmasy plants that
were we now have in the front but we
bought those and they were really cute
just
looking outside the window and then just
seeing like nature there yeah
flowers plants and we saw two birds fly
up to them that was pretty cool
yeah we're gonna eventually just fill
this up with plants
and then paint this floor oh and then i
also ordered
these bar stools and they're so cute
such a fan of those barstools i can't
wait till you guys see it when it comes
but yeah barcelo's there and then i
guess that's it
now we're really really done oh wait no
and then i have to cover this wall
somehow
and then we're really really done anyway
now we're gonna get on to
putting that beast up we're switching
that one out and we're gonna have
this tv go up there and the other one
we're selling it that's the plan
ignore the trash people that they're
driving by
but yeah we're about to do this
are you ready no yeah let's do it
[Music]
all right so we got there's his reaction
because i'm like oh i almost
passed your reaction we got the old tv
off of this mount yeah mounting wall
mount yeah wall mount that's what it's
called
wall mount wall mount wall now the tv
wall mount i remember because isaac
likes to say well instead of what about
he goes what about
what but yeah so here's the old tv
we took off the back brace thingy that
connects to the wall mount
and then that's all i hear now oh yeah
wall mount
when it came down to figuring out the
legs we had a little mini panic attack
because i was like
oh no i think i threw them away i don't
know what i did with them
and then so we have two of these roku
tvs right and so i'm like oh my gosh i
hope i at least saved the
legs from the other tv that we have
mounted in our bedroom wall
and luckily i did so here we go we got
the legs
we got the legs mounted i guess now all
we have to do is move it upstairs
and but that'll be later first we're
going to focus on mounting this we'll
just move this
upstairs to get it out of the way and
then next is
mounting the brackets to this big
baby look at this masterpiece of
technology right here
is gigantic can you imagine watching
something on this already
like what are we gonna watch like this
like movies tv shows
all of it all of it we're gonna do all
of that are you excited for the new tv
yeah you don't care cutie tv cutie
we bought this a long time ago to mount
up the tv and it's for the sound bar
and while we were searching for this box
i looked in
this closet and guess what i found guys
our
x-mas stuff that one box of christmas
stuff that i was like
wait a second we had more stuff yeah
it's all in here
we get to decorate a little bit more so
the problem with this side of the house
right so
safe to see if we're going to put this
head over here tis the season there we
go wait but we're not decorating right
now okay
but it is something that i wanted to
update you guys
on because i'm like oh i found the
christmas stuff that we thought we lost
did we find the garland and [ __ ] in
here i bet you is this
oh it's this one no wait wait wait what
is this it feels like this
yes here it is oh now we get to have an
indoor
indoor garland yeah yeah see this one
this one's lit up oh we can
that was an upgrade that one's like a
more little one yeah but it's also way
longer this one's shorter
we're not decorating wait but what's in
here
just kidding just kidding okay so
another thing
that i'm like uh oh the way we mounted
the other tv was like this right so it
had
holes in it for us to mount the tv
but this tv doesn't have holes so
what do we do hopefully we figure it out
are these okay to remove or is it part
of the tv
because the other tv had holes that are
part of the tv like screwed in
stuff but then it had other holes that
were just available for us to put a
backing like this
there are holes right there so i'm like
okay
this is the power button this thing is
huge you can never miss it oh yeah
that's gigantic that's like comically
big
yeah but it's cool because like you know
if you're ever missing the remote
control
you're like i guess i need to go up the
seat and press it yeah like you don't
ever
use the tv buttons and you're like
where's the on button
it's true i never missed this guy yeah
it's just one button
all right so as much fun as it is to
just be blindly
and aimlessly trying to figure this out
um
i was like now let's save some time and
we pulled out the instruction thingy
that came with the tv
and it says here to mount on the wall
remove the four screws that we
see here so we get to remove these guys
and then we can put in our wall mount
bracket
[Music]
all right so we got the mount
or the bracket thingy for the mount on
the tv
but then now we're dealing with the
sound bar situation
and on the last tv we weren't able to
connect the sound bar
to the tv we had to buy these l brackets
and i ended up painting them
on this side let me see see i painted
them black
because i hated seeing the the chrome
and then now that we're trying to attach
it to this tv
it's too wide and it's not lining up
to where we need it to line up in order
for us to screw it in
so now we're screwed there is no other
place
for us to screw this bracket into yeah i
don't know how to fix this
i have no idea how to get this onto here
oh yeah does the tv come with anything
for this stuff here no
oh that's for the sand yeah we're smart
we'll figure this out
right yeah we'll figure it out all right
so
i am such a genius because i said well
wait
a second this is a sliding thingy what
if we slide it out
and then now we can reach this and
that's what happened
but as i was screwing screwing this one
into tightened
this is what happened we actually broke
a thread
yeah so we broke a piece of plastic from
the tv and that's why it wasn't
tightening
at all so take it out we're gonna take
it out and see if that will help us
tighten it see i told you we're smart we
figured this out
also just to point out look at this
cheapy tv
as soon as we're tightening it the
entire plastic was bending
all right i think we we are out of
threading
is it not tightening yeah it's not
tightening at all
oh no what are we gonna do you put super
glue down here
and just drill into the super glue i was
told if you put super glue and baking
powder together it turns into some like
crazy hard concoction and you can like
basically
melt everything together it actually
turns hot too if you put those things
together
then are we able to screw into it and
now we're able to screw it out
see oh no yeah this tiny little thread
just ruined all of our plans all right
so we discovered the issue
and we came up with the solution so
here's what happened
all right so we were using these fatter
screws
because this is fat enough to get
through
the spacers and like these brackets and
then get to the tv right
so we discovered that once we were
screwing in the holes
as you can see the black hole is bigger
which allows for a fatter screw
but if you get right up in there there's
a metal like a
metal threading thingy for the screw to
actually cling on onto
but that is only for the skinnier one
which means
no wonder this was bending because these
screws
are all holding on to just the black
piece
the plastic piece so that's why these
were able to be okay and then once that
tiny little piece of threading this
thing
broke off of this part it no longer
allowed us to
tighten it like we had for the other
ones so the solution here
is we're gonna go to the hardware store
and then
get this screw but get it way longer so
it can at least be as long as this one
and hope that that solves all of our
problems
that is what we're hoping that is what
we're gonna go do let's go do that
all right we are home now
[Applause]
why poor why it doesn't work
does screw in but like two threads
like this and that's it there it is
so with the spacers and just this it
fits it works look when we went to go
check out the screws
the next longest one was like this long
yeah i'm like
[Applause]
i'm thinking maybe we can do the glue
gun
yeah glue gun this is annoying
why do we have such bad luck with tv
stuff every time
okay so here's what happened since the
last update
so we went to the hardware store we came
back it was wrong
and then we went back we got longer ones
still wrong ac went out to the hardware
store again but this time with different
hardware that has more
options and then he went there and then
he picked
two different sets so then he picked
these which is these
opened oh would it tell me the other
thing that you found out so i found out
that there are
two ways to measure screw sizes the ones
i bought the first time around are
measured in the
standard size like the american standard
size and there's the metric size
which is what these came in and i bought
quarter inch nails
or screws and they they're they're so
close if you look at them they're so
close but yet
so far apart there's still two and these
are m6s that i've learned so
now i know there's a metric system for
screws so the first thing was trying the
longer ones because that's
the length that we need right and then
what did we find out
it fits it fits well
there was a problem is that we've been
screwing everything with screwdrivers
but these don't have screwdriver
thingies on them yeah it's for the rest
of the wrench where the wrench goes
right here and then that works and the
lift it's sturdy
finally it won't move anywhere so were
these sturdy sturdy in your opinion or
should we redo these ones too
i think they're pretty sturdy but you do
have a point so
the fact that these are just on the
plastic look at the plastic i know it's
super warped it's so warped but yeah the
fact that they're on the plastic
i also would be kind of worried because
what i'm thinking is these went in
and it hit the middle part yeah and it
just stopped
yeah but the plastic part kept going up
and up and up
bubbling up exactly i think we should i
think it might be
safer to switch it out if you think once
this goes on the wall
they have the weight of the tv hanging
on and the plastic has to hang on from
your life to
keep the tv from falling out and i feel
like the plastic is going to rip
yeah maybe i should switch it our
beautiful
[Music]
just like that this is never ending
we're gonna watch a movie on this tv
tonight no matter what no matter what
we're doing
we're
all right guys you have been with us
throughout this treacherous journey
and i can now confidently say everything
is screwed on
baby yes baby now it's time
to put it on the wall
[Music]
so we got the tv on the wall
tada we're exhausted from so many
problems
and problem solving but we got this dang
tv up on the wall
there is one last issue though that
we're just too exhausted to try to
figure out and solve the issue here now
is this tv is tilting all the way
forward because
these guys that are supposed to tighten
it into place
for some odd reason they have to go
in this way to tighten but then as you
can see there's this bar here in the way
so there's a screw here inside and we
tried using this to tighten it it did
not work
but this is the part where it tilts
there is no way to tighten this as of
yet that just means that we're going to
have this tv tilted all the way forward
and that's just what we're gonna have to
live with right in the meantime yeah it
works well for when we're sitting down
smart way to do it is to take the tv off
completely which was a hassle to put on
in the first place so maybe if we
brought a friend over and helped us
take it off and then maybe we can have
some time and safety
uh to look at the the screws yep because
as we were trying to get this tv on the
wall it was just me and casey doing it
right so then there was a moment where
he couldn't see anything and i could see
what was happening
but then we were losing grip and i was
like
i remember like this is sparta kind of
moment where i'm like just
go just push it on there because as soon
as we let go
i already knew like it's gonna be game
over for this tv and we're just exerting
as much energy as possible
because this thing is freaking heavy so
we ended up making that happen
and we got it on the wall so good
teamwork
[Music]
where's your hand
wait one two
how cute it looks like you have a tiny
hand one two
three three there's one
oh mine got stuck
[Music]
you know you don't get satisfaction from
smelling that like no packaging material
no i'm good on that i just like peeling
it
it's like the new car smell of tv
[Music]
um
you shall pass
thank you oh
that was scary
[Music]
thank you but this time hold my hand
okay because last time i stepped on it
you're like
oh my goodness okay this one like that
and let's look look
final last bit tada
we got our new tv i heard like oh my
gosh i'm like
oh people oh no it's because these
stools
look scary plug it in and turn it on yes
what are we gonna wash tonight yeah
we're
gonna put the up tv right there in the
middle
no it has like a little grip yeah we're
so scared like let's just
the only way we're gonna touch this tv
is from here to tilt it
towards the kitchen and tilting it back
look at this guys i took a trip to
hawaii really quick i'm on this
helicopter tour don't tell casey just
kidding
our tv is all set up thankfully
our tv problems and adventures are
done for now because we're still to try
to fix this tilt problem but
honestly it's not that bad like i think
we can live with this
it's not it's not too crazy but anyway
thank you guys so much for watching and
i did want to give a shout out to
today's sponsor thank you so much
squarespace for sponsoring and
supporting this channel
and in case you didn't know squarespace
is a platform that allows users
to create beautiful websites for
whatever industry you're in for example
if you want to create a photography
website to showcase your work
squarespace offers professional
portfolio designs that allow you to
customize the layout
the look and feel of your work then when
people want to hire you for photography
you can add online booking and
scheduling straight through squarespace
taking the hassle out of coordinating
your calendars with clients
squarespace also has some powerful tools
to grow your audience through email
you can create email content that
matches the feel of your website
so everything feels consistent and stays
effective go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're
ready to launch go to
squarespace.comcase to get 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
so thank you once again squarespace and
thank you guys
so much for watching this vlog i hope we
didn't
frustrate you as much as we got
frustrated in real life because you got
to have
just the clip clip cliff notes i guess
versions just the highlights
the frustrations all the the the
wrench throwing and
and we got this baby all set up now so
until the next time we have to deal with
this beast
of a tv but thank you guys for watching
thank you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
yeah you